do you have any update on uh dead to me
season three do you know anything no i
don't
i know it's finished but i don't know
when it's coming out um and it was a
tough uh a tough shoot to get it all
completed but um i know we're all really
excited for people to see it what was it
like working with christine i know she
had this health announcement yeah well
it was it was a challenge but she's a
warrior and she just hit it head-on and
she's she's working through it and um
you know there was there were moments
where we'd know what it was before she
was diagnosed and and um just all just
very concerned
for her but she's you know she's a
battler and she you know she's getting
through it and uh but uh it was it was
the the show took a backseat to her
health for sure so um but we're all
surrounding her and uh giving her the
you know the best wishes and the best
love and yeah but she's a tough one she
really is
nancy edward robert congratulations oh
it's what they call a fixer-upper yes
once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from
which you can sing i see it now
okay what did it feel like to be jumping
back into this character not only the
character but literally jumping back
into it yeah jumping back into it like
like dance choreography and whatnot
after 15 years it doesn't quite come off
you the same way at the end of the day
does it
no no you take it home with you for sure
but it's uh i was just happy that all my
joints still worked right it's been 15
years and and i'm here with my daughter
she's experiencing d23 with me it's
super fun to have her here and like talk
about this movie and i don't know i
think for the longest time we didn't
know if it was gonna happen right it was
like they talked about uh you know a
sequel but we didn't know what the story
was and everyone's schedules or whatever
and i'm just happy that we actually got
the thing in the can and uh got to put
the suits back on and like you said jump
around dance around and um get to sing a
little bit with adina which is pretty
cool yeah that's my dad right pretty
great she's pretty great um is your
daughter like is she into this stuff or
is it like
she's into the like conventions right
like everything you know we went to uh
comic-con earlier in the year and she
loves all of that and the cosplay stuff
and she know that you played cyclops oh
yeah yeah yeah i'm not sure that she's
discovered that one just yet or maybe
she's sort of wonderfully underwhelmed
by it
i don't think that's it i think it's i
don't know if that's her jam gotcha um
but uh
but i don't know maybe she secretly
enjoys it but um but no she just loves
the enthusiasm she loves seeing the fans
out there like going die hard and and uh
yeah it's fun fun to share all that with
her considering these are the movies
that i
you know she was raised on